hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 10 hört zu und spricht nach
aufstehen aufstehen dann stehst du am
morgen auf dann stehst du am morgen auf
ich stehe um zwanzig nach sechs auf ich
stehe um zwanzig nach 6 auf am ziehen
anziehen was ziehst du für die party an
was ziehst du für die party an
ich ziehe ein kleid an
abwaschen lässt du das geschirr abwäscht
du das geschirr ab
ja ich wasche das geschirr ab
nein ich wasche das geschirr nicht ab
einkaufen einkaufen
ich kaufe im supermarkt ein
er kauft lebensmittel ein
für das abendessen ein wir kaufen für
das abendessen ein abfahren abfahren
wann fährt der zug ab wann fährt der zug
ab er fährt um 9 uhr 35 ab
um 9 uhr 35 ab ankommen ankommen wann
kommen wir an
wann kommen wir an wir kommen in zwei
stunden an
wir kommen in zwei stunden an anfangen
[Musik]
anfangen
der kurs fängt an der kurs fängt an
wann fängt der deutschkurs an
[Musik]
träumen aufräumen
ich räume auf ich räume auf ich räume
nicht gern auf ich räume nicht gern auf
ich räume nicht gern die wohnung auf ich
räume nicht gern die wohnung auf zu
machen zu machen
machst du die tür zu machst du die tür
zu machst du jetzt die tür zu machst du
jetzt die tür zu kannst du
die tür zu machen kannst du bitte die
tür zumachen 99 deutsch deutsch heute
heute die leute die leute der freund der
freund ich laufe du läufst ich laufe du
läufst der raum die räume der
die räume der baum die bäume der baum
die bäume das haus die häuser das haus
die häuser
achtung achtung der schnellzug nach
zürich fährt planmäßig um 16 uhr 15 ab
achtung achtung die s9 verspätet sich um
fünf minuten
sie kommt statt um 1220 um 12.25 uhr
bahnhof an
entschuldigen sie die verspätung
vorsicht auf gleis 3 vetter intercity
nach lugano ab vorsicht auf gleis 3
zugs abfahrt hallo ich nehme jetzt die
s8 bis nach thalwil
ich steige dort um und nehme dann den ic
um 9 uhr 35 komme ich in luzern an
holst du mich am bahnhof ab
achtung auf gleis 5 bitte treten sie vom
geist zurück der schnellzug hält nicht
an und fährt durch den bahnhof hallo
mami mami kein problem ich kann schon
selber zu fahren
ja ich steige in basel aus und komme
rechtzeitig an macht jedoch keine sorgen
achtung achtung
der regionalexpress hat einen elektronik
schaden bitte steigen sie nicht ein
der zug muss zur wartung ins depot
steigen sie nicht ein und warten sie auf
den ersatzzug vielen dank für ihr
verständnis